ich für meinen teil habe heute etwas
mitgebracht was mich bewegt und ärgert
und zwar ist es der wahlkampf mit
kindern für meinen geschmack werden in
diesem wahlkampf viel zu sehr die kinder
beeinflusst und instrumentalisiert
begonnen hat mein ärgernis letzte woche
bei den bildern die sie gerade sehen wo
im tipi bei prosieben die
kanzlerkandidaten von kindern befragt
wurden das system der kinderbetreuung
ist ja eigentlich ganz nett aber die
fragen haben keinesfalls von den kindern
selbst gestammt werden einen knopf im
ohr wo fragen durchgegeben wurden ein
kindheit beispielsweise armin laschet
gefragt ob hans georg maßen ein nazi ist
ja das sind die fragen die kinder
wirklich so richtig bewegen aber das war
noch nicht der höhepunkt der höhepunkt
erreichte sich dann gestern für mich als
nämlich geht schritt wurde von der
grünen direktkandidatin jette nippert
ich komme von einer grundschule und bin
am heulen die kinder fragen zu rassismus
warum frauen weniger verdienen
klimawandel und tierschutz eine hat sich
nach der stunde geoutet weil ich so
coole antworten zur sexualität gegeben
habe für diese jungen menschen mache ich
alles kinder interessieren sich also nur
für rassismus warum frauen weniger
verdienen und den klimawandel nicht
anscheinend dafür dass die maske tragen
müssen der grundschule oder für andere
themen die grünen mögen dass er sehr
gerne kinder zu benutzen um ihre meinung
zu sagen vielleicht weil sie sich selbst
nicht zum traumberuf stärke dafür zu
haben dass andere beispiele die berliner
spitzenkandidatin der grünen bettina
jarasch unterstreicht den wunsch zum
klimawandel mit einer aussage des
elfjährigen jungen carl der wurzel
gesagt haben soll bitte bitte trödelt
nicht mehr so für mich ist es ganz klar
wer kinder im wahlkampf für sich
sprechen lässt das ist das politische
ende
da würde ich sagen schön wäre es wenn
das politische ende klar das ist eine
mechanik die wieder kommt in unsere
politische kultur eigentlich gelernt aus
diktaturen die diktatoren geben kinder
lassen sich von kinder gerne mal einen
blumenstrauß gehen oder auch analysieren
das ist eine gelernte grund mechanik in
demokratien hatten wir das eigentlich
nicht wir haben instinktiv die sphären
getrennt und das war auch gut so es ist
aber über kreta zurück gekommen greta
ist ja die inszenierung eines empörten
kindes im grunde genommen ein
minderjähriger der ein handicap hat für
eine politische botschaft missbraucht
wir stellen uns nochmal vor kreta wäre
die tochter von herrn orban und würde
für seine einwanderungspolitik agitieren
wahrscheinlich weder herr orban schon
vor dem menschenrechtsgerichtshof längst
verurteilt
von der anderen seite wurde das
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert also dieses
gerät ab phänomen kinder zu missbrauchen
für ideologische und politische zwecke
das aber ich finde das kann man nicht
miteinander vergleichen weil bei kreta
der fall anders liegt wir wissen ja auch
in der historie des dass aus ihrem
antrieb heraus passiert ist dass sie
selbst auf die straße gehen wollte dass
sie für ihre werte da eingestand ist
kann man sagen okay das wurde dann am
ende von ihren eltern mit gekapert oder
von denjenigen den aktivisten mit
gekapert aber ich glaube es ist kein
vergleich zu den kindern die jetzt hier
von politikern genutzt wurden die ja
noch viel viel jünger waren
beziehungsweise sind als kreta in dem
alter als sie angefangen hat wir
erinnern uns an dass wir erinnert
gleichen standort aber wir erinnern uns
ja an das berühmte an das berühmte bild
und ich finde bei greta bei aller kritik
die die vielleicht auch gerechtfertigt
ist finde ich machte es bei ihr einen
sehr authentischen eindruck und das hat
nicht nur damit zu tun dass viele
aktivistinnen da auf ihrer seite sind ja
bei greta war es genau andersherum
dieses bild das wir alle kennen wie sie
vor dem reichstag six mit dem streik
schild war ein inszeniertes foto einer
großen pr agentur in stockholm und die
eltern haben firmen gegründet und mit
diesen dieser marke greta geld zu aber
die eltern ist man auch in seinen das
stück habe ich das immer die eltern
hatten ja nicht die idee greta sozusagen
zu klima ikone zu machen sondern sie
haben wir aufgenommen und taschen heim
sie haben aufgenommen was kreta
empfunden hat was kreta sozusagen als
thema für sich und für ihre jugend
identifiziert hat und dann ist daraus
das entstanden also man kann nicht sagen
dass sozusagen die idee an sich von den
eltern kamen dann wurde kreta gesagt
mensch klima ist ganz wichtig deswegen
musst du das jetzt machen ich glaube
darüber anders herum
also sabine beikler sich aber auch dass
die intrinsische motivation von kreta
selbst kam aber der punkt den er trotz
und geschmiert wird ist das die ganze
fußbewegung eben darauf beruht dass das
kinder sind und was mir daran zerstören
ist dass man über kindern immer
automatisch davon ausgehen dass das
moralische haben ist was sie von sich
geben das passt ja auch so gut zu den
grünen oder also kinder sprechen
wahrheit und so und da geht nichts
drüber und dafür wiederum durch so
drüber gehörst man kann einfach an die
widersprechen sogar fragen würden das so
niemand greift ein kind an weil das ist
ja wirklich unmenschlich also das steht
mir meisten dieser diskussion ist alles
sieben anläufe ihre eigenen thesen um
irgendwie mehr schwerkraft drauf zu
legen also die kinder die kinder haben
panik klimawandel frauenquote das sagen
uns die grundschüler und wir kümmern uns
darum und ich frage mich manchmal ist es
auch immer so anonymisiert ich frage
mich manchmal wirklich ob es diesen
kleinen elfjährigen karl gab in genau
der situation ob diese frau an der
grundschule war und kinder wirklich sie
nun nach diesen themen gefragt haben die
sitzen damit maske den ganzen tag und
interessieren sich anscheinend am
meisten für den klimawandel und für
bessere bezahlung für frauen es kommt
mir merkwürdig vor entscheidende punkt
ist da steht natürlich die gerät da ist
ein bisschen ein anderes phänomen als
als das regal in deutschland beobachten
aber was natürlich bei greta der punkt
ist dass sie eigentlich diesen
durchbruch der infantilisierung und der
kindes fixiertheit aufs tapet gebracht
hat das also alle jetzt quasi diese
kinder zum absoluten referenzpunkt
erleben gestern haben wir darüber
gesprochen
die micky maus regiert deutschland
gewissermaßen im klimabereich also die
kinder reagieren die micky mäuse
regieren und das ist natürlich auch
ausdruck eines zerfalls wenn man so wie
der elterlichen verantwortung dass man
dort die kinder auf dem podest steht und
mir kommt das so mit diesen kindern hier
jetzt das nicht dass greta thema das die
kinder als menschliche schutzschilde vor
die politiker gestellt werden die diese
kinder einsetzen um ihre intellektuellen
also zum teil hochgradig dürftigen
positionen emotional abzubauen und damit
genau das passiert passiert den gesagt
dass ich einfach nimmer mehr traut
einspruch zu erheben erleben und das ist
natürlich auch dass das motiv dahinter
ist eben das schlimme man setzt diese
kinder als menschliche schutzschilde ein
um eine debatte zu finden aber die
debatte rede gegenrede ist die essenz
der demokratie aber auf der anderen
seite muss man doch sagen also wenn wir
jetzt über kinder reden erstens glaube
ich war das jetzt kein massenphänomen
dass das ständig passiert ist es bei
allen parteien passiert und
auf der anderen seite finde ich ist es
ja auch richtig über kinder zu sprechen
wenn wir uns sozusagen das
wählerklientel anschauen dann ist unser
problem ja nicht dass die kinder ein
besonderes mitspracherecht momentan
haben sondern vor allem ältere menschen
wenn wir uns in unsere überalterte
gesellschaft anschauen ist es so dass
das was zum beispiel jüngere menschen
wirklich bewegt junge erwachsene
mittelalte menschen bewegt dass das im
vergleich zu dem was zum beispiel
senioren entscheiden können weil sie
mehr sind viel viel weniger ist aber
dass er von total homogen in gruppen aus
also das untergräbt ja also mit minz
davon ausgehen dass wir anteilig so
viele kinder wie im pensionisten
senioren im parlament sitzen haben
müssten wird es ja komplett unserer
repräsentativen demokratie männer
sprechen also verstehen im punkt weil
interessen also ich kann es bis zum
gewissen grad nachvollziehen aber wenn
du da beginnt jetzt auch kinder
irgendwie zu hören mit rein zu nehmen
dann öffnet irgendwie die büchse der
pandora weil du könnte dann auf alle
möglichen jetzt nicht nur weiter sondern
vielleicht auch äußere merkmale gehen
und sagen die sind auch nicht
repräsentiert also ich finde immer ein
schmaler grat muss sollte sich absolut
auch für kinderrechte und sonstiges
einsetzen eklat aber es muss doch
möglich sein mit den menschen die im
parlament sitzen so wird bei der gerade
noch einmal ein problem bei dieser
prosieben-sendung zb ja wo die kinder da
sitzt und plötzlich kommen fragen also
es mit hans georg maas ob der nazis das
wird nicht das ker uns sicher nicht
nötig sei natürlich was willst du mich
erwartet von armin laschet dass ihr
aufsteht und sagt bei dieser
instrumentalisierung mache ich nicht mit
aber die zeiten von armin laschet in dem
fall aber kann es natürlich sorgen
source ja ich bin also beeindruckt von
der politischen hoch bildung dieser
kinder mit dem knopf im ohr und ich gehe
mal davon aus das ist denen nicht
eingeflüstert wurden die haben sich also
schon seit jahren die siebenjährigen mit
hans georg maas nach dem landesgesetz
das ist eine satirische durch ganz gut
wenn ich als kind zurück denkt in dem
auto da hat mich vieles interessiert
mich micky maus hätte mich interessiert
aber politik interessiert mich nicht
also ich misstrauisch und der ganzen
versuchsanlage
polit und deswegen ist ihr punkt auch
richtig es ist eine verschiebung des
politischen commerce in der politischen
kultur hatten wir ohne es zu definieren
aber wir hatten eine stille vereinbarung
dass wir das nicht machen und das ist
auf einmal in diesem bundestagswahlkampf
so sichtbar waren meine these ist das
ist im greta mimikry woher kommt das
eigentlich und es kommt durch dieses
vorgangs ist auch verzweiflung der
politiker die offensichtlich ihrem
eigenen inhalt nicht glauben deshalb
müssen sie das eben emotional auf plus
damit diese kinder
instrumentalisieren mit diesen
schutzschild aber ist auch eine pr
industrie natürlich den grünen führen
wir auch diesen anderen fall wo eine
trainierten eine eine trainierte
pr-managerin ein junges mädchen für eine
andere fernsehen und präpariert hat
macht den laschet fern und dann ging er
die sendung und
sah dann auf einmal ein junges mädchen
das wie so ein profi sprecherin in
attackierte das sind im grunde genommen
deformationen der politischen kultur
[Musik]